Hello and welcome to Rawkode live. I am
your host Rawkode.
Today is part three. It's the final part
of our clustered KubeCon special.
Before we get started, there's just a little
bit of housekeeping. First,
you're not already a subscriber, please subscribe now.
Click the bell and you will get alerts
for all future episodes of Rawkode live where
we explore the cloud native landscape together.
If you're watching live or even if you're
not watching live, but you wanna talk to
a few hundred other technologists focused in cloud
native Kubernetes and Docker and containers and all
that cool fun stuff, there's a Discord server.
Come and say hello.
And lastly, I wanna thank Equinix Medal. They
are my employer, and they allow me to
do this on their time. So thank you
very much. If you wanna check it out,
use the code Rawkode. This will get you
$200
in credits.
There's roughly around four hundred hours of compute
if you spend it wisely.
If you wanna have a bit more fun
with it, you can spend it pretty quickly.
So let me know how you get on.
Alright. Today's guests for joining me on custard
part three KubeCon special are Jiffy and Chris.
Hey. How are you both doing?
Doing well.
I love that, Bex. I just saw the
question of both people and see who who
answers first. But
Jiffy, do you wanna say hello? Tell us
who you are, what you do, and then
we'll move on to Chris.
Sure. Hello.
My name is Jeffrey Sika. Pretty much everywhere
on the Internet, I'm known as Jiffy, so
they're kinda interchangeable.
I'm a principal software engineer at Red Hat.
I focus mainly on CICD with, managed distributed
systems like, OpenShift dedicated.
I'm also a
CNCF ambassador,
so I'm kind of all over the place.
And I'm a Kubernetes contributor, so I'm a
SIG chair for SIG UI, so Kubernetes dashboard.
And I help out with Kubernetes
community and also Slack admin, YouTube admin, that
sort of thing.
Thanks for sharing. Chris?
Hi, everyone. My name is Chris.
My day job is a customer engineer with,
the Canadian public sector at Google Cloud.
In my off hours, I do, do some,
committee.
I'm nervous and terrified and excited right now,
so I'm gonna stumble a lot. It's gonna
be fun.
I
contribute to Kubernetes as much as I can
where I can. I got the fun little
Kubernetes
contributor shirt.
I do this primarily through the monthly office
hours, which is also cohosted by, by David
here and, as well Pop. So, if you're
looking to learn more about Kubernetes, that's another
great way to engage and interact with the
community and learn a lot of fun stuff.
So,
I'm excited to see what we can do
today.
Well, anxious, excited, and scared is the three
things I want people to feel unclustered. You're
hitting all the targets.
Quite a little sweaty.
I just wanna thank you both joining me
because you're both cornerstones of the Kubernetes and
cloud native communities. It's a pleasure to do
this with you today. So Thank you.
Alright. Quite in watch. That's the niceties over.
Now we go straight out to debug.
Alright. Hold on. Hold on.
And that's nicely leads us into. We are
starting with Jeffrey's cluster first. So, Chris, you
and I are up. I am gonna connect
to the control plane node of this cluster.
If you could join the active session and
type echo hello to confirm that we are
sharing a buffer, that would be appreciated.
Okay. So this is gonna show up under
activity active session? That is right. Yeah.
Okay. I was waiting for it to refresh
then.
Come on.
Oh, maybe I'm looking at the wrong cluster.
Yep. One four five, please. Yeah. The two
tabs open, and I definitely went to the
wrong one. So we're off to a blazing
good start today. Alright. Well, you just joined
because my alias set forth. Thank you. Yeah.
Getting
the cube config and alias out of way
just saves so much pain as we dive
in. But I am gonna give you the
honors to run the first cube control command
and see if we have a control plane
or at least an API server.
Let's see let's see what we we have
here. What kind of journey are we going
on today?
Let's check to what notes we got. It's
all ready and working. That's that's
refreshing. Very nice.
I know I've given this.
No. There's no niceties here. You got basic
tip control, and that's it. I thought I'd
check.
Yeah. And I'm just worried that this is
like an exam. I'm gonna forget everything I
ever learned.
That's alright. We're just gonna be And we're
doing this together. Talks. Yeah.
Oh.
So we have one or two restarts.
Yeah. We have both of our workloads here
at the default namespace,
but crash it back off and over a
thousand restarts.
Control c works as the copy and paste.
Right?
It's probably gonna send a sec term to
the
the terminal. It does capture it and work
it. So you might wanna do a shift
and insert.
Yeah.
Control shift and insert, whatever that is. Yeah.
Oh, I'm doing a bunch of bad stuff
right now. I'm just gonna type it out
because this is already off to a good
start. Sorry. I'll just Web terminals are my
forte. No worries. Here we go.
Yeah. There was the clustered, what,
two months ago where I pasted down my
password or typed my password into the session.
That was a that was a good thing.
Yeah.
I I might do something like that. I
haven't done a debug on a computer in
probably about a year, so this is gonna
be a this is good times.
I just have to reload, but I'm good.
Okay. What have we got? Readiness probe failed.
The probe failed?
Oh,
let's see.
Let's see if Postgres is giving the same
error.
I feel like it should be also checking
for CRDs,
but we'll get to that.
Yeah. Let's take a look at Postgres first.
Yeah.
Paste it.
There we go.
We're just getting loads of evil faces from
g p in the chat. So I'm not
even looking at me. It's you're looking inside
of my face. I'm like, in the terminal
over here, and then the camera's over here.
So hope you enjoy the side of this.
This isn't a good bet.
So
what we see with this one then, he's
obviously changed the image because this is the
Jimmy Hong Carnetti's image on our post credits.
Apologies. I didn't even look at the images.
Was looking at what it described.
That makes that makes sense. Yeah.
I wonder if that's gonna be as easy
as just fixing that back to the postage
image that we expect or not. But we
can get we can get that a try.
Robot history.
Robot history. How fancy.
Oh, yeah.
That's what I came here for.
Alright.
Like, I think for the first four episodes,
I would just do, like, a cube control,
delete pods slash dash all, and then people
kept yelling at me going, roll out, restart.
What are you doing, you animal? And then
so I
started to try to clean up my act
a little bit. Less sledgehammer,
more dancing.
Mhmm.
Okay. So we can see the
revision.
But you never left a change cause. That
was rude. No comment.
I'm curious how much of your screen is
actually off the screen because I only just
now saw error Okay. With no history. I'll
try to keep it up top. I've dragged
it back up. We should be good. Cool.
Cool. Yeah. There's yep. Yeah. Thanks for the
reminder.
We got a reminder in chat as well.
I need to stop.
I have Thank you. I use this window
thing that adds padding to all my windows,
but not quite enough for the bottom of
the screen.
Yeah.
So I just need to check to see
if there's a hunker NetEase or something in
there, but no. I'm just gonna spin up
a local item so I've got access to
the real resources and manifests if we need
to.
Well, we will probably need to take a
look. Yeah.
Let's see what happens if I kill that
pod.
Let me just do.
Journey is he gonna send me on? The
postgres image is just postgres with the tag
13 dash Alpine if you wanna try
spinning it back. I don't know. Did you
revert to manually there?
Not yet. I just killed it just to
see what would happen if when it spawns
back up.
So I'm just waiting for it to do
it. So it's saying, and then, yeah, we'll
we'll change the take back to normal.
This is where we twiddle our thumbs.
Yep.
I just want you to know that I'm
even nervous, and I'm the one that broke
it.
We're getting closer, warmer, colder?
Yes. Oh.
Alright. This is the restart. So I think
that that probe's gonna fail after x attempts.
Yep.
I I I say we just revert the
image. Oh, hello. Now Derek came to say
hello.
Say we just replaced
the image
to what we expect and then we'll try
and tackle this this clustered one maybe.
You know, I will I will say one
thing. One one little tiny thing.
You haven't checked the logs yet.
Don't don't get me wrong. It's not gonna
help you.
Uh-oh. You just wanna show the logs. Right?
Okay. Oh, yeah.
My process is a little dated, I guess.
Alright.
Yeah. It's still running. Okay. It restarted.
So we're going to
fully
crawled.
Stateful set?
No.
Yeah. The pro schedules are the stateful set.
Yeah.
Are you gonna update the image?
Yeah. Oh, let's let's take a look at
those logs first. I wanna see what Jiffy
said in Forest.
Yeah.
Oh, right. Because that's implied. Oh, yeah. Yeah.
That's a bad habit of mine. I always
specify.
Let's
Alright. Alright.
I think it's safe to throw the image
back to normal now.
Yeah.
Nope. Cool.
And where are we? That's about 20 lanes.
Oh, I think it went past it. Yeah.
There you go.
Oh, wow.
Sneaky.
See what else is in here.
Expect containers.
Can you search for honk in this file?
You're
gonna have to remind me how to search
in UI. Forward slash.
Forward slash.
No?
Okay. So
the state's okay. Being thought he was a
mutating webhook?
Yeah. It has to be right.
Configurations,
mutating web configuration.
We there's no auto complete. It's really annoying.
Okay.
I'm sorry. K get.
Mutating would you want me to type for
a bit?
There you go. I have it. That hooks.
Yeah. That'd be great. Yeah. You're it's just
configurate. It's just such a weird
Nope.
So it doesn't mean that there isn't one.
There could be a static one in the
API server manifest.
Although that would be sneaky because it'd have
to compile his own API server.
Yeah. You are a sneaky gif.
Okay. We can switch over to
just drop out of that and go into
one of the
nodes. Right?
What do you wanna check on the nodes?
Yeah.
Oh, we can. I'm just not sure what
to check on the nodes.
Like, let's let's try and think this out
because this is
annoying me already.
Something is Yeah.
Just wanna take a look at the stateful
set again
or say the pod.
Map.
See if there's anything weird in here.
Alright. Do you mind if I try something?
Yeah. Go for it.
Ever
run for
dot
stock.
Can you list images? Yeah. Okay.
There it is. I was wondering if there's
maybe, like, there was multiple aliases on the
image and it was you've shown us the
default even with the other one and there
was, an image pool policy perhaps,
but
I don't think that's the case.
But we can rule that out
Mhmm. By switching this to always.
It's not doing anything.
So I don't think my my idea is
right.
Yeah.
Okay. That time's gone.
Yeah. No. I keep coming back to the
webhook, but yeah. So what else could modify
something in the cluster?
So I'm
trying to think.
Let's see if there's anything
suspect in the API resources.
And I'll check one more thing before maybe
I start trying to talk it load again,
but what if we got running across the
whole thing?
Okay.
There's only one
other thing I think this could be. And
then I'm probably completely out of my depth.
Container d allows you to set overrides on
an image.
I
was worried there would be some yeah.
Is
not something I've played around with yet. So
this is gonna be a fun adventure, a
learning experience.
Yeah. I'm not a fan of trying to
debug this stuff either.
Where is it? Container d is in Etsy.
Cry?
I
just started studying for my CKS.
This is going to keep up with me.
So container d is running as a system
d unit, so there could be a system
d overlay maybe.
You try
system d cat system d cat container d,
and it shows
the.
Alright. Sisters.
Sorry. Can't, did you say? Yeah. Cat.
Oh, cat. Yeah. That should print out all
of the
not called overlays and system d. Can't remember
what they're called. System
system CTL. We've been really Oh, sorry.
No. No worries.
Nothing. I'm seeing honk just in the root
words.
Where is it?
And there was definitely no container d here.
There's no.
I'm a very naughty goose.
I I I appreciate it,
This is good.
Some someone said, what's up with the guy
in the middle? And I'm not talking. It's
because if I talk, I might give a
hint and give it away.
Yeah. Okay. So I think gonna get you
talking. We need to get you monologuing. Is
that it? I think Tahira is just not
familiar with the new format where we have
the breaker live to laugh at us. So
the breaker will be mostly quiet during their
cluster.
That's very true. Because NF, as they say,
can be used against them. So Yeah.
This is
my
brain is struggling to understand what's going on
here.
Do you do you want a hint? Not
yet.
K.
Okay.
So the
stateful set shows the right image. That's what
that's the best grading on me because Yeah.
I'm just trying to think if you can
have a stateful set that the pod be
controlled by something else, but
can't.
Okay. Let's check the control plane. It's not
been messed with. Can we go to the
static manifests and maybe see if any of
those files look like they've been
Yeah.
Where is it?
It's a true Kubernetes
manifest. Yeah.
Yeah. We're Kubernetes.
Seeing every small Kubernetes.
That's the pressure of people watching you typing
always just
It's Yeah. It's a combination of stuff. Right?
Oops. Sorry. I just did the long
I was gonna do the exact same thing.
Great minds think alike, fools seldom differ. Right?
So he's not been tinkering.
I mean, he What did you give us
access to this?
Well, he could have changed the dates on
them. I don't know if he'd be that
of a terrible goose, but I'm trying to
look look at his smile and see if
anything's slipping out.
I'm really this is my poker face. My
my stupid smile face.
Just just take comfort in knowing in, fifteen,
twenty minutes, I'm gonna be the one in
pain. Yeah. Yeah. That's true.
Where could it be?
So there wasn't any mutating admission controllers.
Yeah. We didn't see Kiverno. He hadn't deployed
anything new to the cluster. Right?
Yeah. I did that whole namespace, I think.
I just wanna double check.
You
god.
I'm trying to match together my hotkeys I
have on mine versus yours, and it's just.
And we never seen anything in the container
d directory to suggest an overlay.
So
there's a command on container d.
Oh. Done.
There we go.
I'm gonna have to remember this one. Thank
you.
I don't know if it's gonna be helpful,
but Could
better than staring at the screen.
I'm
almost at the stage of going to the
root directory and doing a grep minus r
honk. That that's where we're getting to here.
Alright. So we got barlib container d. I'm
gonna I think we should check that out.
I think
I mean, do we even know that container
d is real?
Let's see. And then you swap out the
binary. Right?
That's why I was hoping when we did
the
I'm just gonna slowly go up.
So I was hoping something would show here.
Well, let's try doing along on
March 11. Okay. So maybe not.
Let's see. Version.
Doesn't say honk. That's a good thing. It's
a delightful. Alright.
Let's think out the box for two more
minutes before we maybe get a help.
Yeah.
Just
cube.
Yeah. Resources.
Did we already do this? I think we
did.
Yeah. I scanned it, but I didn't look
in anger, to be fair.
It's really turning into Jake Pisteck cloud kinda
kinda scenario. I like it.
Alright. Let's
let's but we're we're not covering the basics
here. We're we're getting caught up at the
moment. Let's look at the logs on container
d. Let's look at the Kubernetes event log.
There has to be
a there's gotta be a thread to fill
on here. There has to be. Yeah.
CTL dash l?
Dash l dash u or dash l u
and container d. Oh, yeah.
And if we don't want the pager at
a dash f as well.
Oh, the u has to be in the
end because it's the unit name.
Alright.
What have we got?
Image.
Create container. Create container.
Looks normal ish.
Nothing is
popping up.
So I'll take a look at these logs
again of that postgrads.
So KB has asked, is there a proxy
somewhere?
I'm gonna go on 11 and say no.
It has to be in cluster.
At least I feel it has to be
in cluster because the stateful set has the
right image.
Mhmm.
So I I I don't think it's a
proxy.
Alright. Let's try the events. Get events.
Present.
We're not friends anymore,
Jeffrey. I'm sorry.
I'm not I'm not sorry, but I do
feel bad.
You've
you've done your job very well.
So what I'm thinking
is we could nuke
the stateful set and try to reapply it
to see if this weirdness persists.
But then we don't really
I suspect it may not. I'm not sure.
And then I don't know
if we'd ever find out what it is.
Could do a rollout restart.
Let's
would you mind if I take for a
moment? Because I don't really know what I
wanna do.
Yeah. And I'm my
brain's a lot like, maybe he replaced something
in Postgres there that's
calling the API server or
I think one thing he's done something.
I have I've absolutely done something.
Oh, can I try?
Oh, yeah. I'll let you.
I just wanted to see if we had
a kubelet fail here. We do not. I
wanna see if
our lib
kubelet config has anything suspicious.
You can feel free to try whatever you
want. I
k. I'm I'm running out of ideas.
API server one word, and you'll need dash
u per unit.
And dash l k v p I. Thanks,
They're saying it's always DNS.
Maybe not. Thanks, Yeah.
There's no logs in the API server. That's
terrifying.
Oh, because the API server is a static
pod. So we'll need to get the logs
from
Oh, right. Yeah. It's
Okay.
It's been a while since I used it
since they switched over to that. Yeah. This
this is if you don't if you don't
use kubidm on on a daily basis, you'll
lose track of where stuff is.
Yeah. Alright. I'm I'm I think I'm gonna
ask for a hint. What do you think,
Chris? Will we get a hint? Yeah.
Unless he wants to watch us flail for
a little bit longer.
No. No.
However, you get one of two hints. You
can either get a hint, which is the
backstory of what happened to the cluster, or
you can get a hint about something you've
already done.
Cool. So did we get close at some
point?
Pick pick your
do you wanna do, dude?
I'm gonna leave this decision entirely up to
you. What do you want?
I'll take the hint of for something we
got close to. The story is appealing, but
I think we can we might be able
to ink the thread a little.
Right idea, wrong folder earlier.
It has to be the container d overlay.
Oh.
Alright.
I'll give you one other hint.
Not container d.
Always move to config somewhere?
Oh.
Okay. So the static
pod directory could have been reconfigured.
Yeah. So we wanna take a look at
the
Kiplit config after all maybe.
See, See, part of my problem is I
don't know whether to say warmer or colder.
And I don't know how much you want
to flail. I don't know how much fun
other people are having watching you.
People seem to enjoy watching me suffer on
the show. I've gotta say.
It seems to be the fun part, at
least the the learning part. I watched the
session yesterday and a couple others, and it's
entertaining just seeing the how people try to
approach debugging the clusters. And
I I love seeing people work real time
because everyone works and troubleshoot differently.
Yeah.
Like, yesterday, there were some awesome awesome hints.
I will I will also say
that
I was going to do something different
because I thought this idea was way too
mean.
And when I saw some of your previous
episodes and went, nope.
Nope. I'm gonna do it.
I
did I did get opinions from both Christophe
and Bob
about whether this was too mean or not.
Here we are. Okay.
Alright. I'm just gonna cut this.
And I will I will leave it up
to both of you whether you want another
hint or not.
Can we just let that fail again?
So the static pod path had not changed,
which I
am happy to see.
Yeah.
I was gonna move over to the cube
API one again, see if there's anything kinda
Yeah. Red herring there. Yeah. That's it.
Yeah. I guess, yeah, the the next hint
would probably depend on how much time we
have left.
I cannot remember.
So
the hand was wrong directory.
Yeah. You you were you were talking about
something something, but it was the wrong directory
just to think about it.
Oh.
What directory is it looking to?
Yeah. I'm trying to we've been in Let
let me let me also say, not just
wrong directory, wrong project.
Do you put Cryo in here?
No. There's no there's no Cryo.
I'm pretty sure. I
will I will tell you the story of
the cluster.
This cluster
was a cluster
run by an intern
at a school.
Nothing really important was running on the cluster,
but we got a
notice that we needed to upgrade the cluster.
So the intern upgraded the cluster.
I
don't know how they upgraded the cluster, but
they did.
And then six months later, all of a
sudden, we have this we have this issue
where we can't schedule any workloads.
That that's our hint?
Yep.
Sounds like certs.
Oversell to the it it can
what? I wanna see what happens if you
deploy a pod. Can we just do, like,
a
NGINX deploy just to see if that goes
up. Or
Yeah.
Oops. Please.
I'm really excited. I can I know this
You you can type?
It worked. Okay. We're put a load on
it, make sure it actually is NGINX.
Yeah.
You,
my friend
Ugh. Having a good time. I
I'm glad to chat or join it.
You are creative.
And you're saying it's not container d. So
it must be the kubelet. Right? Something
I'm committed
to working on what he's done to our
kubelet now. So let's
go take a look at
No. Okay. Next.
Okay. So using standard here. Barrelib.
Kiplit.
We already looked at this.
I also do have one more hint when
you're ready.
Don't talk to me. What's he doing?
What's he doing?
Let's do.
Nope.
Let's do k.
I
mean, that is all of
the Can we list the pods that are
running again? Oh oh, what? No. Never mind.
I thought I saw something.
Can we see what Hunker NetEase is running?
Or
can we check the logs on Hunker NetEase?
I'm being silly. Right? He he he won't
have affected the Kubeflow on this machine.
Mhmm. So we're I just wanna see what
that We need to be on this machine.
Which one? S x six.
Because workloads won't be scheduled to the control
plane, and we're bouncing around the control plane,
which I think is very naive of me.
So
I've opened a session on s x six
if you wanna join.
Yes, yes I do.
And let's look for irregularities on this kubelet.
Let me just reload since you've joined.
Okay.
So
barlib.
Alright.
That looks okay.
Next
Our flags here.
Let's take a look at the parameters.
What?
I'm sorry.
It was good.
What I didn't bother.
Alright. We're gonna give it five more minutes
and then
Are you gonna wanna know the answer or
you're wanna put this in the pocket?
No. No. We'll get the answer. Alright. Yeah.
The audience will demand it.
We need clarity for what what your nefarious
honking you did.
Alright. Can I ask a couple of questions
right before you
I let me let me also give you
one hint, the last hint I was gonna
give? We talked about
our backgrounds when we first joined the call
before we went live, and I said what
my background was.
I'm a developer. I'm not an ops person.
Go ahead and ask your questions.
Should we be in a control plane node
or the worker node?
Yes.
Did you build your own container to do
something?
I did not. Well, technically, I built honker
Netty's Jiffy, but I didn't build Fair.
I didn't build postgres.
I didn't build a new clustered.
Yeah.
Just does the binary, wasn't it?
How did you get the strings or something
again?
I don't remember. I thought it was just
string. I
will I will also save you time. I
did not put any honk bread crumbs in
outside of the log.
Did you build your own criplet?
Yep. Alright.
I've got an idea.
It's like, how do we
why
is that not working?
I'll keep it Oh, yeah. And it really
needs to remove everything.
No. I have bar, the cache.
I have bar cache
as after.
I was hoping for a nice debian package
here.
Yeah. How do we do a reinstall? Aft
install.
Well, it's good. I've just upgraded to Kiplit
too, so there we go.
Hopefully, that doesn't make new breaks.
Alright. I think we have the normal back
on this machine, but that doesn't mean
that he hasn't done that on every other
node, assuming he has Yeah. Has his own
kuplet.
I can go back to the other one,
and I can restart.
And, hopefully, that
Yeah. Feel free just to And your next
is back up and running.
Or it's wait. No. We need to check
vlogs.
Yeah. It's not been restarted yet.
Yeah. I got I got excited. I saw
the one. It's like, yes. I'm gonna go
check the other two machines just in case
the is different on them all.
If you wanna change the workload.
I will
I will say,
you are correct.
You have you have solved it.
However, there was a second part of this,
which is you have to assume that all
of the nodes and the cluster itself are
owned.
Oh. There
are no root there
are no kernel changes. We did not host
the operating system.
You just repointed us to the an outside
cluster?
No. No. I think didn't Seconk do that
or, like, roll into a cluster inside of
a cluster? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
I'm giving it to you because
you you have absolutely figured it out. I
compiled my own cubelet and placed it on
all of the notes.
What you what
you don't see
is in my terminal window every sixty seconds,
I'm SSH ing to those nodes and overwriting
cubelet if it's been changed. Because I wasn't
sure how long this was gonna take and
now I feel bad.
So I've already seen
I've already updated Qubelet twice so far.
You're very quiet, Tanya. That that last bit
is
I mean, we'd we'd never
be able to work that out. That's harsh.
Yeah. But Yeah. It's a nice one. Well
played. The the idea was
if someone has a cluster that they didn't
know, like, how it was installed or how
it was managed, they can't actually validate the
supply chain. So they can't validate that Cubelet
is actually what it should be.
And if a cluster has been taken hostage,
just fixing the cluster isn't necessarily gonna fix
the cluster.
That was that was my idea. That was
my little Disney story arc of being really,
really mean. I'm sorry. So from now on
Good. I'm disabling SSH access on all of
these machines. That's crazy.
Hey. Well done, sir. I I stopped you
before that came into play.
But it's probably a good idea. Yeah. See,
this is one of the thing. This has
happened before, right, with the binaries on the
machines is that
if someone does swap out the binary that
is 99%
functional, it's really hard.
Like we need better at and through Falco
and there's other tools that we can work
in the space that would tell us this.
But you know, by default, we have no
idea that those binaries have been swapped underneath
us. And that's
a common
theme there that I'm seeing people abusing on
this show. So nice nicely done.
I I feel like it is a really
good lesson because that's also something like, that's
a problem if you're running your own cluster.
Like, that's a benefit of managed offerings is
they're they are going to be the ones
managing the whole supply chain start to finish.
When you're managing your own, there are just
so many different things you need to think
about. Yeah. I'm gonna write a script to
start doing checksums and all the binaries. I've
I've seriously considered,
like, starting that as a project just because
of this idea. Like, there is no real
good way to do that across the whole
stack.
Yeah. Alright. Well played. Now,
we switch roles.
Yep. Now I'm gonna feel the pain.
Hopefully.
Like, this is this is my first time
purposely breaking a cluster. So this is either
gonna be really easy or it's gonna be
interesting.
Alright. Well, I have opened a session on
Chrissy's control plane. If you could please join
and just give me an echo or something
so that we know. I'll set up the
KubeConfig.
Session.
I I already see typing. Yeah. I get
a weird screen refresh when that happens and
my scroll breaks. I'm just gonna reload. It's
a teleport. It's such a cool project, but
they need to fix this bug.
Alright. No more hump, please. Come on. Right.
I
will give you the pleasure of seeing if
we have a control plan.
Alright.
So far we do.
So far, we are only missing
the the website.
I'm gonna try, George.
I'm gonna try.
Yeah. Make. Please make me try.
Interesting. So we have zero of one deployments
ready.
Nothing up to date.
Okay. So I I just realized that it's
not gonna show. So I'm scrolling through here
Oh, yeah. Just to see yeah.
So there's one desired,
zero updated,
two unavailable.
Also, rolling update strategy, 25%
max unavailable, 25% max surge.
Well, it looks like we got an old
replica set and a new replica set.
Maybe something
is there no scheduler,
maybe?
You you go hard already.
I think he's had a rough rough couple
sessions.
He's gonna be checking the checksums on every
binary.
Oh, we have admission. Oh, gatekeeper. Nice.
Alright.
So
error creating admission webhook validation gatekeeper S h
a s h. Yep. Denied the request. So
gatekeeper's been installed
and apparently is denying
all pods must have a clustered label for
branding and association.
So, Chris,
if I
add that label, what's gonna happen?
Oh, you're just gonna find out.
I'm gonna try to drag this out as
long as humanly possible.
So let's edit this.
I'm bad at the Kubernetes.
Oh, okay.
You can just add labels.
You want me to do it? Yeah, please.
Alright.
So
what was the warning on? Was it on
the pod? Was it on the it won't
be the pod. It was the pod. Right?
So we need to It was the pod.
So, yeah, we need to add the label.
Oh, I'm dumb. Yep.
Yep.
Alright. So we've added our label. Do we
have pods?
Of course not. Alright.
So whoop.
Control w does not work in terminal browser.
I've done that so many things.
That's exactly what I'm gonna do.
Oh, no. We got No. Alright. So the
replica set
Oh, we got an invalid. Alright. Okay. So
we've also got something blocking us from deploying
anything that isn't an ancient database to IO
repository.
So we need to take a look at
the
what does gatekeeper call policies again?
So I've tried to pepper some Stargate references
throughout this. Just
Appreciate it. I always appreciate that.
That's awesome.
So we got required labels.
That's the there we go. Allowed repositories.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Load.
Ancient archive of knowledge.
Mhmm.
Gotta watch out for this.
I love it.
So you allowed all the control point nodes?
I'm not
super mean. That's first time. So I just
wanna start start simple.
I I will
will just bounce back to my cubelet patch.
My cubelet patch allowed anything in cube system,
Cilium, metal l b system.
Something else.
Didn't wanna throw too many flags.
I'm gonna suggest we just delete.
Okay.
Allowed repose
ancient archive of knowledge.
Scaled it up. On a way. Yeah. That
was the last message. I thought we'll need
to Yeah. Maybe do a rollout.
Yep.
Alright. We got another denied.
All parts must have a clustered label for
branding and associated.
Branded and associated Stargate unit?
Is
I mean, I don't know gatekeeper. Is s
g star like, Stargate, or is it gatekeeper
specific?
Yeah. All the the teams that go to
the port the Stargate would be s g
one, s g two. Oh.
Oh.
Alright. So let's look at our API resources
again. So one of and I'm assuming if
we do that
okay.
No. No. No. No. I think we need
to update the label to not say Rawkode
and Gfi,
but to say s g 1. Well, I
was gonna just take a look at the
policy so that we don't
guess. Oh,
that's that's much better.
Maybe. Just an idea.
If you want to, probably smarter.
I'm enjoying this, but if you wanna do
that, by all means.
So
required
labeled
Dash o y m o must be
clustered.
Alright.
So
does that actually see
Alright. I have to scroll up on mine.
Yeah.
That would be a cool feature that I'm
gonna have to ask the the teleport team
to work on that.
I love teleport by the way.
Yeah. It's awesome. And you were also right.
Custard cannot be David and Jiffy. It has
to be s g dash
number.
Yep.
I'll give you the owners.
No.
If I no. No. If I'm reading this
right, we can just have a key of
clustered,
but we also need another
key called key. Oh, you're right. You're right.
I was hoping you were gonna it looked
like you're gonna miss it.
Oh, you hey. Off you go. You you
take it away. I'm just
I'm just over here.
I've already exceeded my expectations, so this is
great.
Match labels.
Template. There we go.
Boom. Boom. Let's see what SG we are.
I'm saying we're SG one.
It's the best SG.
Yep.
Oh.
You may have to do a
well, in fact, the labels would have done
a rollout, so it's just not working yet.
That's true.
I guess we're going back to the event
log.
Yep.
Well, okay. So it
set it scaled,
wrap was set to zero, and then scaled
it up to one.
You wanna try the rollout just in case?
I thought labels would've
What did we roll out command.
Was it rollout deployment?
Roll out restart deployment clustered.
Yeah.
Hit control w again.
That happens to the best of us. Yep.
Alright.
Let's describe our deployment.
Yep.
Well, it's yeah. We need two keys. One
of them had to be clustered with any
value, and one had to be team with
s g one
according to the policy.
Oh, wait. Really? Yeah. No. No. You're you're
right. I think, well, it misinterpreted
the policy the way I did it first.
Yeah. You you did it right, at least.
That's how it was intended unless I Unless
I typed up.
Just possible.
Okay. So minimum replicas unavailable,
progressing through new replica set created.
So it's not scaling it up at all.
Yeah.
Okay. Now can we check for a scheduler?
Damn it. Alright. Okay.
Because we're not getting any errors. Right?
No. We're not getting any errors at this
point. Deployment controller is saying it's scaling it
up and down correctly.
I'm
just gonna type randomly and you've got
keep keep going because you're following what I'm
following. I see two different replica sets that
have a desired of one and I think
that's part of the problem. Okay. So we're
still getting hit by a Oh, there's a
validation
policy too.
And it has to do with the image.
The image. Yeah.
So we probably
there's probably a different yeah. A different
gatekeeper CRD that we need to look at.
Okay.
Key. That
came back.
I'm really fast with SSH.
Okay.
So there's either a rope process on this
machine.
Chris has another terminal open just to mock
us like you did.
I'm so sorry.
Give me.
Nothing in the cron tab. That's the next
thing I was gonna say.
We have a rule system
fail.
It was lit normal.
Can I take over for a sec? Please
stay.
So real quick quick.
Sorry. Just for the record, the scheduler had
a restart, which I always find suspicious.
That's fair.
Oh, look. It's running flux c d.
Oh.
No.
I I say we delete that entire namespace.
After
you.
Of course.
Right.
Alright.
So we got a policy. We've got a
at a mission controller, it's talking about deleting
the namespace.
So
let's take a look at validating
webhook configurations and then mutating webhook configuration.
Or it could be RBAC. Maybe it's just
simpler.
Yeah. If I say too much, I'll give
too much away. So I'm just gonna a
silent
observer.
We've not had anyone take a approach to
sabotage. That's a nice touch.
I
want to point out no. No. No. I
wanna point out something, Chris. And this this
is a little bit of a tangent, but
it's worth it. When we did the first
honk CTL session
with Bob and I are sitting there, Everyone
else is trying to break the cluster as
hard as they can. And here you come
in, try install OPA, try and lock down
the cluster, try and preserve the cluster's health
while everyone else is trying to destroy it.
Just a reverse hog. That's all.
You
you are a lawful good, Kubernetes.
are a lawful good, goo.
Thank you.
Oh, sure. I'll break the cluster.
Policies on it.
Just just not how you expect.
I love it.
Yeah. There we go. We gotta validate and
webhook to block the deletion of
namespaces.
Yep.
I'm gonna try this again.
I'm warning you, Chris. This better work.
I will say this on a policy I
put in there. So
I don't know where that one came from,
but I'm enjoying that one
very much right now.
I mean, we could just delete the pods
in that namespace and that would get what
we need done.
Yeah.
You're right. There's no R back here. We
got root. So it's definitely at a mission
controller of some kind.
So you're suggesting we could do a
customized controller.
Done.
And so now we can probably
go back. Okay.
It is terminating. Yeah.
So now we can probably go back and
delete the ancient archive of knowledge. It shouldn't
come back. We might be good.
Yeah?
Alright.
Our custard pod is coming up.
Is that it? Did we do it?
It might be a little bit more. Alright.
Of course.
Container creating.
Yeah. Like, hopefully, it's just building the image,
but
CNI.
Failed to find plug in.
Oh, there's no Cilium.
Oh, wait. No. No. Wrong namespace. Sorry. I
do that all the time.
Oh, no. There's no ceiling.
That's sneaky.
We still have the namespace by the looks
of it.
Oh, wait. What?
Hold up. So
three are ready.
I am going to, like, mentally delete control
w from my memory.
Yes. Just don't please don't hurt me after
this. It's all.
Oh, we're gonna have to roll out everything.
Alright.
What is the rule out demons restart demon
sets. So the
Oops. Sorry. Here we go.
It's the same note.
Oh, no. Wrong new space.
Is gatekeeper back?
Is it?
Other oh, that's the wrong one.
That one's not back.
What other CRDs are there?
Yeah. Thank you.
What about disallowed
tags?
I see how we're playing the game there.
I'm not even looking at him, Chris.
It's definitely a thousand cuts on this one.
Yeah. So this break does have a story.
It's I, a Kubernetes administrator, misconfigured a few
things, and this is the ensuing chaos that
you get.
It's mean.
I didn't mean for it to be that
mean.
I love it.
Alright. Okay. No. So so what's happening Yeah.
Go for it. Go ahead. No. I was
gonna say what's happening here is we never
deleted
the policy
for the clustered pod. We just added the
labels and got the clustered pod working. Cilium
isn't scheduling because we haven't added the labels
to the Cilium
staple set either.
But I just removed the policy.
You removed disallowed tags.
Did you actually delete the the other policy
as well? Alright.
Okay.
I just have to delete an entire CRD
namespace. Is that a thing?
There we go.
Hey.
Alright. My host of cards is slowly crumbling.
Alright. So we need to do a rollout
of
same operator too.
And technically, the Hubble stuff if we care
about the state of that right now. Yeah.
We can probably get away with oh, there
we go. We have a clustered.
Chris?
Yes?
Hold
on. Actually, I shouldn't clap. Is it working?
Let's go find out.
Go to the website and find out.
I knew it.
We'll see if it works.
My man is not looking good.
Insert evil laugh GIF. Right?
Yeah. To be very unhelpful, my application doesn't
actually log anything. So
Okay.
I'll give you a couple
more minutes of this, and then I'll and
then sake of time, I can give a
hint
if
if you need it.
Alright. So
the pod is running.
Now we can't we never really get the
port forward long enough to load the page.
It could be
that it's timing out. We didn't speak to
the database. So let's describe the postcard service,
see if we have any endpoints.
Good point.
Describe
SVC
Postgres.
Alright. So we got one endpoint.
No. Counter application actually speak to it as
the other thing.
Do you wanna check for network policies?
Chris is stuck mostly to the Kubernetes API,
so I'm assuming
we have a net poll.
I don't know them all.
It's
tell you I'm cluster wide network policies and
sell you network policies.
I think I think you can just do
net pull. Get net pull.
There we go. An iris.
Do I got it?
That's good.
Alright. Let's get that in the bed.
Yeah.
If you'd looked at the allowed tags policy,
it was all, had a list of, the
various planets in the s g the planet
codes.
Alright. Put forward looks health fair.
There we go. There you go.
Was Nice. That was good.
Chris, I love that.
Yep. Thank you, Chris.
Thank you for going on that that little
adventure. That was a it's fun watching.
Alright. You two have a decision to make.
Yep. You have twenty minutes in my cluster
if you wish to take it on.
If you wanna look around for twenty minutes,
you're more than welcome. If you wanna call
it quits and move on with your day,
that is alright.
I know twenty minutes is not a lot
of time, so that's why I'm gonna make
it completely optional.
I would feel awful if,
like, the two of us have made you
suffer.
You don't make us suffer. But you know
how bad my weekend will be if you
solve this in nineteen minutes?
Alright.
Feel free to take a look around.
Take a look around.
Alright.
So let's do the obligatory k get pods.
Oh.
Oh,
I wanna make sure I'm in the right
cluster.
P4X639
is the the worst world charge. Just FYI.
And I pop I am not crying. Thank
you very much. I am holding that in
holding that in well.
Yeah. Are you on the Which one is
Replicator planet or
black hole? A window of opportunity.
Window of opportunity. That's the infinite loop one,
Groundhog Day. Oh, the best episode. Yeah. That
one. Awesome. Alright. I've set you up. That's
all I'm doing.
Appreciate it.
Are
you in the same
back discussion, Chris?
Yeah.
We got rejected.
Yep.
So we're back at our request for an
unknown reason.
Is it actually up and running? It's my
That is.
Feeling.
Such a good episode.
Yeah. It's not on Netflix up here in
Canada yet. I'm waiting.
It comes on in The UK every now
and again, and then I start watching it.
But then I can't get through all 11
series before they take it back off again.
You're stuck in your own little loop then.
Yep.
What
did he do?
Well,
server rejected a request for an unknown reason.
Mhmm.
API server is up and running.
Do we have any logs from the server?
Oh,
Oh, they have a chaos kubectl on there.
That's
nefarious.
Mhmm.
Are you also typing really fast right now?
Oh, wait. Are we in the are we
in the same terminal?
Yeah. So I can
Okay. Okay. Cool. Yeah.
I'm still coming down off the watching. Little
little shaky right now. So You
know, that's like I let me also shout
that out. It's it was actually
scarier for me to be the breaker than
it was for me to be the debugger.
Maybe that's weird.
Oh, a
lot of pressure. Like, can you break a
cluster?
Oh.
Oh,
there we go.
Yeah. I think that's the part I was
worried most about. Debugging is fun, yeah, properly
breaking something, it's
doesn't come natural.
Bucks of tears. Bucks of tears.
Client con switching balancer to pick first.
So
I've never seen this
go ahead. I was just like, did he
swap out the binary too?
I have never seen
this chaos thing.
Did he maybe change some of the config
the cube config?
It's deleting some stuff.
Yeah. It's deleting clustered and then
no idea what else. Okay.
So
cube config or yeah. The KubeConfig might be
a good example. Let's let's see what that
is.
We're we're good to show the KubeConfig on
screen. Right? Yeah. It's all good. Alright.
I would answer that question pop, but I'm
keeping my language clean this evening.
I don't see anything
out of the ordinary here. So maybe it's
not this. Yeah. It's the endpoint. Right?
Yeah. I think so.
What do we have here?
One four what is it? 145.
It's not any of
the addresses here.
I
think it's going to the wrong spot, but
wouldn't that would no. Would it have timed
out if this was going to the wrong
server?
So I'll I'll spare you going down a
rabbit hole. That is the EIP and the
correct IP address for the API server.
It is not any of the node IPs,
but you don't know the setup, so I'm
just gonna give you that.
Much appreciated.
I my my initial thought was he swapped
IPs with one of our servers. Yeah.
But didn't change the certs, so it would
throw an error like this.
Yep. And and, like, I'm looking at I'm
looking at the teleport IP, like, is that
the same IP?
Ditto on my end. Alright.
So we still
Midna has decided to wake up. We still
have no idea why we don't have access
to the API server.
I do know
that
this chaos pod or chaos container is definitely
going to stop us from
it's it's gonna kill the cluster pod What
if we get access to it. What if
we delete that chaos pod?
That's a nice idea.
Let's do it. Let's see if it's outside
of Let's come back.
Oh,
wrong thing.
I'm gonna have to start practicing my Christ
ETL, I think. Oh, no. It's gone.
No.
And it's back. Okay. It's being managed by.
I'm leaning towards something with certificates.
Yeah. But, like, if it's the wrong cert,
wouldn't it just stall and then give us
the
old cert error or x five zero nine?
Or am I behind on my error warnings?
Remember in the beginning when I said I'm
more dev and less ops? You probably know
better than me.
Okay.
I'm
footing both doors
a little bit. I'm trying to remember I'm
trying to remember the curl command so we
can just hit the API server and see
if the cert works that way.
I'm happy to take the curl command for
you if you want.
I was just gonna Google it if you
have it up. Yeah. If you got it.
I mean, that's that's the next path that
we're going down.
Yeah.
Yeah. You could start our DNS.
See where was that IP address. Would it
would it be DNS, though?
I don't like, I would assume if it
was DNS again, it would stall for a
bit because that response was way too fast
in my Do you want me to
Run it again?
Right. Because it should hang if it's just
it's trying.
Did you need the the URL,
David? That's alright.
Alright.
Oh. Uh-oh. You
got a cat over there. Cat.
Cat. Cat.
Oh, no.
It is.
I just have my desk up high enough
mine can't jump. It's great.
If you saw my desk setup, you'd laugh.
Cat tree over here. Cat bed over here.
Cat wall behind me.
I have a cat chair in front of
me. He
spent the mornings snoring.
It was great.
Alright. So so here we are.
Certificate problem, unable to get the local issuer
cert. It is still safe.
Sir? So the certificate is fine.
The cert is fine.
The cert is fine. You've already seen the
problem twice now. That's all I'm saying. Oh,
right. What
if we wanna go back to twice? We
have catered the cube config twice.
Mhmm.
And we've looked at the cry output couple
times.
This is in my breaker notes as a
superficial problem.
Breaker notes is superficial problem
because it
probably has to do with this.
What where's our KubeConfig pointing to?
Etcetera, Kubernetes, admin Com, unless you mean there's.
Yeah. This okay. So it's pointing to the
file that we're looking at then. Yeah.
Yeah.
Would you just like a hint Well, I
think the the
yeah.
There we go.
It's only one context.
No. No. Like
Does the context match the name?
Kubernetes hyphen admin at cluster o two five
KubeCon EU twenty twenty one cluster o two
five KubeCon EU yeah.
I'll type in it.
Client key data. Client shaver data. I'm surprised
no one in the chat has noticed it
either.
Is it an indent error?
It's worse than that. Like, the Oh. Subtly
worse than that.
Oh, it's the little ones that are the
where
is it?
Yeah. One second. Comes.
And Midna is now laying on my arm,
so this is gonna be a little bit
hard mode.
Did you just I can take over if
you want. I did. Did I do something
bad? Probably.
There's
a type of config and I don't know
if you configs well enough to know whether
that was I mean, you messed like a
huge hint because when you open them, I
actually remembered where my card goes.
Oh.
So you can watch that one back later.
Oh, that'll be that'll be good.
Alright. Just to make sure I didn't
break it worse or better. Okay. Alright. See
how, Chris, you were saying, like, you think
your break was gonna be too simple. Like,
user literally gonna kick yourself when you get
this is just the slow you down problem.
It's a little
Okay.
So you confirmed the IP address, which I
thought was nice.
I'm confused.
Again, like
bringing up a config file on my Thank
you. Machine
so I can see.
I'm I'm stuck on this. Why don't you
def it with one of the other ones
and see if something's different?
What other ones? Like my own? They they
you can def it with the Kubelet one.
Papa's saying, can he call a friend and
can that friend be Thomas Stromberg?
As
much as I enjoyed having Thomas on, he's
barred.
Oh, Christophe sees it.
Thanks, Christophe.
Oh.
If chat sees it, don't type it. Or
rather, you can control what pops up. Right?
So, like, we won't see it. Yeah. Yeah.
I will show you. Okay.
When I don't sneakily have the YouTube channel
opened anywhere else. So
could you could you vim or cat the
the file again?
Yes. Just keep in mind have this config
file over here. Cool. Look what's here. This
is the diff between Qubelet
and cubes
Oh. Calling.
So you can probably ignore the sercs because
they use different sercs. It's a kind kind
or type bit
at the top. Yep.
Yep.
Yeah.
So
Oh, crumbs. I gotta get to get to
something in five minutes. So
Here it is.
Is that
there.
No?
Do you do you have your own KubeConfig?
Yeah.
Do. Get rid of preferences.
These are swinging swinging and missing there.
Yeah. And I'm just looking over here. I
don't have it. It's just delete everything.
That's that's how it's going. Right? Yeah.
Nuke it from orbit. It's the only way
to be sure.
Alright. I'm gonna put my own.
Because, like, I have a good idea.
Oh, it's because I have, like, a zillion
con things in here.
Client data, client key data.
There we go. I mean The person is
there.
It was in the diff.
I thought it was. That's that's what I'm
looking at. But
So just go through less. Take it slowly.
Really?
Oh.
Cheap.
It's so subtle.
I think I had a dream last night
where that was the problem.
Just in a random config file. Nicely done.
Is so good.
So was that chaos thing a red herring
then? No. The chaos is that'll infect in
chaos.
At least it should be unless I broke
it.
Everything's
here.
Is
it still deleting the
cluster pod? It's running. It's been up for
ten minutes. Yeah.
Because that's what it was doing, right, when
we saw the output? Yep.
And then let's see what the output is
for that now because that is certainly come
on. Copy.
So the funny thing I can't tell you.
Oh,
he's sweet. Nice.
So by fixing your Kubernetes config, you actually
bring the chaos pod into effect.
Wait.
Because the chaos part was broken
because of the cube config. You've now fixed
the cube config. The chaos part potentially is
now chaotic.
The chaos part is actually throwing errors.
Yeah. Because it can't get to the because
it can't get to it anymore.
Yeah. It was working, like, a few minutes
ago, but now it's unless we scroll all
way down to the bottom of output. Yeah.
It's it's giving the same error we got
initially.
You played yourself.
Alright. Can we port can we port forward
the
damn it. Yeah. Do you
Or I can Do have
the thing?
I
David looks like he's thinking.
Do me a favor and delete the chaos
pod.
Sure.
Oh, it's going on 80 k.
Do you just want do you just wanna
open that on stream for us?
Oh, wait. How do we It's how do
you do? It gave me an NGINX.
Sorry.
Alright.
Alright. So Crysi CTL PS.
Crysi CTL
RM. Okay. I gotta jump to a a
meeting in a minute. This has been an
absolute
delight.
I cannot thank you enough, David, for,
inviting me to participate in this session.
Truly
divine.
Oh, thank you for joining us. It was
a treat.
Yes.
And with that, I bid you adieu.
Farewell and take care.
Yeah. No worries. Thanks.
I want to finish this off. Yeah. You
can poke around.
So you've now fixed it. So I didn't
that that's a bug in my I didn't
know that that
I can't say too much, but yeah.
There's no chaos.
There is no chaos and then the cluster
pod will not run anymore. Correct. Because it'll
just get deleted
repeatedly.
Yes. And repeatedly.
And there's a really
once we get to the end, I'll explain
it. But this is a really interesting one,
I think.
Alright.
Very similar to yours, actually.
Rawkode chaos.
Okay.
Wait. If it's similar to mine, that means
it's gonna be some sort of a matter
or
is it though? It's not nothing's remote. You
you can you can see the container d
pod running. You just can't see it in
cube control, which I think is interesting.
To me, that means it's running outside of
Kubernetes.
I'll answer questions if you want, depending on
how long you have. But I won't say
anything more just now.
So how familiar are you with container d?
Not.
Alright. So you can do a container at
cry control pods to see Kubernetes pods.
That's neat.
But you will see chaos is there.
Well, also a bunch of things are not
ready.
I'm not sure if that matters. Where's cast?
Cube
control, etcetera d.
Oh, it's right at the top. It's
Cube name is oh, wait. What?
Okay. So there's only one cube API server
running.
Has eight restarts.
Bad typo.
Pods
shows
cube API server that's part of chaos namespace.
This is mean.
So chaos isn't available either.
You're gonna have to give me hints. Yeah.
There's no chaos namespace.
You wanna talk it through?
So
either
there is something horribly, easily wrong.
I'm, like, I'm trying to decide whether it's
at the Kubernetes level or at the cryo
level or container d level.
Or are they intrinsically linked? It's in the
Kubernetes
level.
You could always check the timestamps in those
files.
That's probably a good idea.
Thanks.
This cluster has been running since 1969.
That's tricky.
Yes. I am.
Where we're going, we don't need I
yeah.
I will be honest. We are already out
of my depth.
Okay. So you're really close.
You're close.
So I'll tell you one thing and then
this this challenge that doesn't really matter. So
this is the bug with Docker
as a CRI. I actually upgraded the cluster
to upgrade it to cluster wherever we look
at it. You use Docker instead of container
d because this does not work with container
d.
The bug is you can have a static
manifest
with a pod that runs and if the
namespace doesn't exist, it will still run it.
So there is a chaos namespace running a
pod and a static manifest in this directory,
but you've not found it yet.
That's
mean.
I love it.
And
you've already said you're not an ops person,
so you might find this a little tricky.
Yep.
Because I don't see but it's in this
directory?
It is in that directory. Do you know
how to hide files on Linux?
Nope.
Alright. Chat, let's help you feel. Help
me out.
This is the point where I would be
googling. So I'm phoning a friend. And by
phoning a friend, I mean, I expect someone
to tell me the answer in YouTube chat
and then
Yeah. David just pop it up.
If Waleed, I know you're watching, Noel, you're
watching. If you just wanna jump on, I'll
send you the link. Feel free. Otherwise, start
typing some
think about how we try to fail on
that.
And if no big guesses any answers in
the next minute or two, I'll I'll walk
you through it.
I enjoyed putting this one together.
This is this is
evil.
That's a really it's a terrible bug. It
was actually my colleague,
Dan Federan, BSD box who worked it out.
I think he typos on the namespace with
the static pod and worked out that it
still worked,
but it doesn't work with container d. I
noticed. I
had to change it on time.
The Docker doesn't
validate it. Although we still get weird header.
Interesting.
Well, we're not gonna use FLS
cheating.
Noel is suggesting, is it a main boat,
a bind mount,
which l s dash al would not show?
It is not, actually.
Nice idea, though.
Alright. So
You need you need that voodoo. Give me
that voodoo.
So it is actually
relatively easy to hide things from LS.
And normally what you would encourage people to
do is an echo star, but I've also
hidden it from there too.
So,
we'll just walk through it. Let's wrap this
up. Please do. Like
Okay. So if you can't see it with
LS
and you can't see it with echo star,
you got to start wondering if it could
have been really cruel and mounted something in
with eBPF. I have not done that.
You could check to see
if the command has been modified,
which it has
not.
The one thing you could do
would be to take ENV and look for
certain flags.
That's a that's a really strong hand for
anyone who's familiar with Linux, but there is
also ways using the environment variables to subsequently
hide more things from the shell,
which I've also sophisticated just for the the
laughs. So
is a particularly harsh one.
So
there is an environment variable
called glob ignore,
which will obfuscate the file from the echo
star
by saying that we don't wanna see any
files that have a backup,
the end and the backup tilde symbol.
So we could unset
the glob ignore.
We still don't have LS, but the echo
star now would work and you'd see there's
a Rawkode. YAML here with the bad thing.
That is beautiful.
Now why does the LS not work?
Because I'm an asshole mostly.
If we go to profile.d,
there's my
bad command. So LS was modified to always
pass a dash b, which means don't show
backup files.
I then replaced an alias for ENV to
also omit and hide the glove environment variable.
Oh my god. I love it. So, yeah,
it was particularly harsh.
But now
you and all the people that are watching
are familiar with the Docker runtime and its
ability to launch static pods into an namespace
that doesn't exist, making it completely invisible almost
to operators except for cry control PS.
There we go.
You're you're evil and I deserved every minute
of this.
Well, I I'd say yours was a lot
more evil than mine was, but I
think that was cool.
This is this is the first time well,
this is now the second time I've broken
a cluster for the show. I really enjoyed
it.
Thank you for joining me for breaking your
cluster.
Some nice little things there. I like the
story around it too. I felt helpless for
the entire first thirty minutes of the episode,
which is the best way to feel during
this I feel.
I felt just as helpless now.
Alright. Well, thank you everyone for watching. Thank
you for joining me. Thanks to Chris who's
already left. He had a meeting to go
to.
There will be no cluster next week, but
I will be bringing it back the following
week.
Gfi, have an awesome day. That was really
fun, and I'll speak to you again soon.
Definitely.
You very much. Was so much fun. Bye
bye. Cheers. Bye, man.